bismillah alhamdulillah Salam alaikum
peace be with you exciting topping today
exciting topic every week continue to
tune and continue to benefit and we're
bringing you to guess and it'd be a
shame if you lose out so I'm not losing
out I'm here and you're here with me and
we're excited because we're going to be
talking about first for the brothers we
can give some advice about marriage for
all the single brothers we want to
motivate them to hurry up and get half
of their Deen fulfilled and the sisters
more precious than any commodity any gem
jewel or diamond we're going to give you
given some advice to the most beloved
that are out there our sisters and
humanity so the brothers and the sisters
we're balancing it out here on the Deen
show don't go nowhere we'll be right
back
this is the thesis betangel
assalamu alaikum peace be with you
online with a cat - peace be with you
brother
sheikh omar suleiman on the Deen show
keep me here thank you for being with us
may the Creator God Almighty increase
you and all the best in this life and
hereafter people urinals instructed with
Al Maghrib Institute mich cat institute
that is correct and what's the other one
mister University and also Islamic
learning foundation you'll you also
teach a comparative religion class at
Moscow this magic at all right I mean
knowledge is very important isn't it
absolutely and our and our way of life
our Deen this way of life of all the
messages of God it's not something
esoteric that you know only a few elite
understand it's something for the layman
for the PhD for the GED man that it's
clear its lucid it's not nebula is this
right absolutely
it's straightforward Salam King so that
the you know a person who has a low IQ
and as a Bedouin in the desert or you
know hanging out in the hood can
understand and also a PhD in physics can
understand it and can comprehend it
absolutely I like what you said the guy
hanging out in the hood yeah he'll
understand this message this lucid
message and the academic absolutely but
it's a problem now if it's hazy it's to
something like hold on I just can't get
it you know the three guards and you
know four or five and a monkey God and
you know worshipping them and the
creation these things go against the
nature of man doesn't it so the person
who's been having a hard time he's been
reluctantly opposing this that's because
what God put in him that natural
disposition to recognize the truth it's
it's a it's giving the red light but now
if they're like one God where did these
guys are just saying worship God it's
attracted to this is that what God put
in us
absolutely and in fact you know if you
study history and this
one of the things that we do in my
comparative religion class if you study
history you'll actually you know there's
this idea that that early men were
wildly polytheistic they would just
worship whatever they feared or whatever
they were amazed by so they worship
lightning they'd worship animals things
of that sort but actually if you study
history you can find that monotheism was
the inclination of men and in fact the
things that they saw that put them in
awe they saw them as manifestations of
God's anger God's pleasure and things of
that sort but nevertheless they believed
in one God and then you find that
religion you know degenerated into first
diet ISM which was or Austrian ISM the
concept of a good and evil God and then
it started to delve into polity ISM and
things of that sort so this is this is a
fact you know if you study or it's I
can't say it's a factor or non-muslim
but for Muslims that is a fact certainly
in history has many evidences in that
regard so we want to take off with this
episode for our brothers in humanity
that are tuning in they might have just
been changing the channel and they're
like you know let me check out this show
the Deen show and they like the message
and maybe they've seen some shows in the
past and the whole crust of the matter
is that the it's calling a person to
reflect about the purpose of life and
the purpose of life should be given by
the owner of life and the owner of life
is the Creator that happens on earth and
he's told us to only worship Him the one
guy all right as soon as you add or
delete then this is a problem you start
to add another associate to God you may
got into Jesus or you make God having a
son
this becomes a problem doesn't it
absolutely yeah so God doesn't have any
sons daughters does he have a DNA like
us like human beings a zip code he's
like you know in the city here there
everybody's not a man and he's not a
ministers would like that too we don't
see he's the man upstairs no he's not
the man he doesn't have a human being
he's no human being and that just makes
good old common sense and now we got
some people's attention now for the
people who've also submitted to the
crater you know there are many things
that are distracting us so we love to
give the advice first goes to ourselves
because look my ears closer to to my
mouth so I'm taking it in first you're
taking it and we want this to benefit
all of mankind tell us now we know that
deaf is a reality we're all going to die
there's a Judgment Day
okay we're true justice is gonna be
served then there's the reward of
paradise and we want to be in Paradise
then there's a Hellfire we want to avoid
that place so as best now that we
critique ourselves so that at the end we
don't end up in some serious trouble for
the root of the problem usually can be
solved if we go back to the guidance the
verbatim Word of God the Quran and the
Sunnah there is a verse in there in
surah Tauba 924 now I'm gonna start it
off can you take off of it and give us
kind of the explanation where God
Almighty is saying say if your father's
your sons your spouse's the house is
what you dwell in and Allah is going
over all the things that we're chasing
in this life are dearer to you than God
are dear to you then His Messenger and
striving in his cause and wait till
Allah brings his decision can you go
ahead and expound on this because many
times when we want to give the advice
the the fancy house that the person
wants to be in you know the material
things the things I didn't want they
don't want to give up and it keeps them
from submitting so elaborate on this
verse from the car well I think that
what God is what God is telling us here
is that it's only natural that you
desire certain things we all desire nice
houses we all desire nice cars we all
desire beautiful spouses or in the case
of women handsome spouses we all desire
these types of things we all desire
wealth but they cannot supersede your
love and your desire for God and you
know in essence it's not you know and
many times we found two extremes in
religion we found poverty being praised
and a person putting himself in poverty
and asceticism and remaining celibate
and things of that sort that's that's
something that's praiseworthy and then
we find you know which is the total
opposite of that which is that you're
allowed to indulge in your desires and
just throw God in there wherever you can
you know and it's some super you know
basically they call them search angels
tree Devils yeah right you don't do
anything during the week you do nothing
and we can say mustered angels and and
Street Devils also we've got it in the
mosques too you know people want to live
their lives in a way that's totally
contrary to the guidance of God and then
at the same time to make themselves feel
good about themselves they'll go and
they'll pray to him and call upon him so
in essence what
this first means it's and and it's the
balance between two Islam is a religion
of balance it's not that you shouldn't
own anything it's that nothing should
own you except Allah so you can want
that stuff but make sure that it doesn't
become dearer to you than God and it
doesn't distract you from your purpose
so that's what we should be reflecting
on that this life is short we do have a
purpose and we should be obeying the one
who told us our purpose is the Creator
right so tell us now moving along why I
mentioned this is because it's so
important to really reflect because one
of these things in the material world
are distracting us and you know at the
end you'll be with who you love right so
we want to love Allah so we can be with
Allah tell us for our sisters or should
we start with the brother let's start
ladies first you know many of our
sisters may Allah preserve them and they
are the gems they are the ones that we
love so much and Allah has honored the
Muslim women she's not one that is out
there parading herself and one who was
out there for that attention from men so
he's given her certain things that will
protect her the hijab for instance right
she's establishing the prayer she's
trying to can we elaborate and talk
about the importance of the Muslim woman
having her Muslim identity and sticking
to it and not taking the identity from
pop culture from Britney Spears you know
from all the other things and people who
only lead her to destruction well I
think that you know it's obviously all
about perception many of the things that
have you know that it's it's a hypocrisy
in our culture that a nun for example
can be covered from head to don't so and
can be considered being developed to God
and then a woman a Muslim woman who's
covered had to do so is considered you
know oppressed and things of that sort
this is the greatest way to show your
honor to display your honor
the struggle of women throughout history
is that don't judge me for who I am on
the outside look at me as a human being
judge me for who I am on the inside
in essence the hijab that state of being
forces everyone to do that you look at
them for who you value them for who they
are on the inside their speech you know
the way they think the
the skills that they have to offer to
society all of this is appreciated in
Islam there's scholarship we have many
women scholars in our history it's all
appreciated because in essence a woman
was not judged in Islamic history by the
amount of cleavage she was showing her
how short her skirt was it was it was
about her developments and that's you
know you get what you you get what
you're looking for you know if you walk
into you know when I take my daughter to
to a grocery store she picks up a bag of
chips I'll let her eat that bag of chips
and then I think and we'll just take it
to the cashier and we'll just let him
scan the back you know the empty back
and they won't mind that but if I was to
try to grab a mink coat or something of
that sort that's preserved in glass and
that's hidden and concealed that cannot
be touched except by a customer who
looks serious and who can put something
forth you know can demonstrate their
seriousness then that shows me that this
is a thing of value and it's not just
for me and many there's a misconception
that hey job is because men can't
control themselves and it's like a
punishment but it's actually to honor
the woman it's to honor her to elevate
her and to give her her do her due right
and her due honor so at home did a loud
were you know we're thankful to a lot
that you know and I and we always
challenge the non-muslims to go and to
ask Muslim sisters was this forced upon
you me as Imam what I used to have to
deal with all the time was parents who
were afraid for their daughters who were
insisting on wearing hijab more so than
than parents who wanted their daughter
to wear hijab was women who were proud
who were going into various fields
medicine law whatever it was and by the
way statistically speaking Muslim women
are second and as a minority of women in
terms of their earning in this country
okay so I mean they're very problem and
they're very devout women and at the
same time in hamdulillah there they
honor themselves with what Allah has
honored them with we're gonna take a
break when we right back with more here
on the Deen show I just want to say very
simple message
one of the beautiful things about our
religion of Islam is the emphasis on
direct ritual
and prayer who's gone directly there is
no intermediary the lights will go on
after the party and the party will end
it's very simple and very clear there
are no superstitious rituals no strange
incantations the time is running out and
you might not make it till tomorrow
and this is something that we need to
think about back here on the Dean show
with Sheikh Omar Suleiman and we you
expounded on the verse from the Quran
which is the verbatim word of the crater
tamper free tamper proof we have it
memorized by millions as preserved to
this day is it right so we talked about
some of the things that you know Allah
is talking about and now we mentioned
the importance of you know being
grateful and thankful through obedience
to the crater but now let's say the
argument comes in yes okay I agree but
now if I wear this modest way of dress
the hijab then the whole attitude
obviously goes with it now I might lose
my job I might not be able to get to the
next level in my business my family they
are going to disown me
for example now does that fit in
conjunction with this verse can you
elaborate on just talk about it well I
think that you know one of the things
that we have to put out there from the
start is that many people will not
choose Islam because they're afraid of
commitment and in essence what we see
happening in our country today is is the
rise of non-committal uncommital
religions or factions of religion so
nondenominational ism Unitarianism so
and so forth and and although the
message might be good whenever you look
at it from a general perspective it
doesn't offer any specifics of how to
draw close to God so yes sometimes your
religion will be inconvenient in this
worldly life you will have to make
sacrifices you will have to struggle
because in any in life anything that you
want to succeed in you're gonna have to
make some sacrifices you want to become
a better businessman you're gonna have
to sacrifice a little bit of time you're
gonna have to sacrifice some friends you
know that are holding you back
so yes you will make sacrifices but at
the same time certainly
i countless times you know you see
muslim women who started off wearing the
hijab who started off concealing
themselves and yes they faced massive
opposition and then it hunted it out
lost parents out of open ways for them
and with time and the same people that
were disparaging them for wearing the
hijab actually came to respect them for
wearing the hijab i look at my mother
and may Allah have mercy on her as a
primary example of that when she wore
hijab she was the first in her family to
wear hijab and she was criticized she
was looked at in such a derogatory way
and you know by many parts of her family
but it happened a lot they came to
admire her and respect her for her job
for her hijab
so much so that when she passed away
some of her family members were asking
for some of our jobs in law so Allah
makes it either Allah will make it easy
for you in this life or the message and
the blessing will carry over after you
passed away and that will reward you in
your eternal life and your and your
hereafter inshallah but you've got to
make sacrifices men have to make
sacrifices too hey you know it's not
just for women to do not have to make
sacrifices to and you've got to
understand that Islam does require a
level of commitments there's no doubt
about it I like what you said sacrifice
Ibrahim alayhi Salaam the Prophet
Abraham he was called the sacrifice and
this was a great test so all of us in
our lives were called by Allah Allah
wants to see is it true that are we
willing to sacrifice what's more
important you know we love our parents
we love we have to we can't enter you
know paradises at the feet of your
mother so you got to respect your
parents but how do you now if let's say
you have opposition from your father and
your mother you know and your love is
strong for them but now is it the point
where you have to draw a line and say I
love you and you kiss the feet of your
mother and you honor them but you say I
love a lot more and I have to obey a lot
you just have to be firm about it so the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
Allah Allah tell him a floofy mostly
alcoholic which means you there's no
obedience to a creation when it entails
the disobedience of the creator
however Islam never gives you the
permission to be abusive towards your
parents now that's why Allah says in the
Quran well in Jihad Arkady - shreeka be
male celica be here any philosopher who
MA if they tell you to do something
which is against what
La Soul just don't follow them in back
but you still need to honor them you
still need to give them your
companionship you still need to kiss
their hands and kiss their foreheads and
and try to be the best son or daughter
that you can be and by the way that wins
their hearts many times we've seen
Muslims new Muslims actually win the
hearts of their anonymous and parents
who were Islamic opes by their character
because they saw the massive change in
character you know and their and and and
the lives of their children so that is a
way of winning their hearts and we don't
just do it to win their hearts it's an
obligation from a lost Mohammed Atta to
be that person it's being to honor them
and to love them but just to say look
I'm sorry I just can't do it here but
all he - and I'm honored his father and
loved his father even though his father
was out to kill him he still honored him
and loved him and so I mean that's
that's the point you know you try your
best
whatever you can do you do you do
definitely tell us now we're going to
talk about the brothers now we talked a
little bit about the sisters ladies
first the brothers now that we also want
to encourage who are single and we know
that this is is it true is half of your
Deen yes getting married so many of us
have gotten sucked in with many of the
negative things that are out there
everywhere you go you got some naked
woman on a billboard you can't even go
to jewel Dominic's osco and you got a
naked magazine in front of you you know
what I mean and I know a brother
personally that go twenty twenties there
he lowers his gaze he hates in his heart
but he'll take a flower magazine and
cover her up so you know this is our way
of just doing a little bit you know and
I'm sure the good people who are out
there you know people of other faiths
they can understand this moral decline
of society jurors and Christians so we
don't like that our women are out there
you know they're they're being
prostituted it's not right but now how
can the brothers defend themselves Allah
is giving us the formula and they're
just the urge is coming out and they're
boiling up inside and you know what this
is a major sin if you fall into a
boyfriend/girlfriend and you're
involved in illegal sexual intercourse
pornography is on the rise
no Muslim should have any part in this
what are your comments and suggestions
what I would say is you know what
Shaitaan tries he tries to do with you
and you know when the whole john edwards
scandal happened there was a whole I
remember Time magazine or Newsweek did a
whole issue on the psychology of a
cheater and in essence when a person
cheats what they try to do is they try
to ignore reality and they try to ignore
the consequences of their accidents so
for example a person that's cheating on
his wife will now pull out his wallet
and show the woman that he's cheating
with the pictures of his kids and things
of that sort he wants to ignore reality
he wants to keep that put away right
he's gonna keep his cell phone on silent
he's not gonna be able to talk on the
phone and things of that sort with us
but he wants to ignore reality and and
ignore the consequences of his actions
so that he can ignore a temporary
pleasure that's the struggle of life
which they thought with the devil and of
course in this regard so in a
pornography you know engaging in
premarital relationships this has life
changing you know this will damage your
entire life in essence every
relationship you go through a part of
you will die with that relationship you
would have had some secrets that you've
given to the other person you would have
you know had a level of trust now that's
going to go down the drain you would
have exposed certain things to that
person and so I mean every time you go
through one of those a part of you dies
your capacity to love dies you become
more suspicious of the next partner the
next partner the next partner you become
vulnerable in one medical journal
I forgot what university they said that
a woman who loses who loses her
virginity by the age and while still in
high school is likely to have up to 17
partners in the next five years Wow
17 yeah because of the vulnerability the
the feeling of vulnerability so this is
for brothers and sisters you go through
a relationship you go through these
things it will have damaging effects on
your life in essence even in marriage
even in marriage you know you'll still
have those those lusts you'll still have
those you know you'll still be looking
all over the place and you won't be
satisfied at home and the last thing you
want to
and that's what's happening here in this
you know here today unfortunately and
over 50% divorce rate in this country
that means when you walk down the aisle
in the United States in our country you
know there's a greater than half of its
there's a greater than half chance that
that person is gonna be battling you in
court for custody or for your wealth
half a chance yeah more than 50% the
divorce rate is riven risen above 50% at
this point but don't stop there we know
Islam is the self-defense to all of this
right negativity evil that happens and
now we look at studies you mentioned a
study from Harvard talk about this study
of people who have premarital sex and
the chances of their relationship coming
to an end just because of this in Islam
prevents this from happening if you just
follow the way of life from the crater
talk about this study from hardware
absolutely well I guess like a 69%
chance or something that your your met
your your marriage will fail 7 right
right absolutely well I I think it's
it's clear you know imagine a society
just imagine I'm not unfortunately a lot
of times we'll do is we'll start to
we'll start to look at societies that
already exist I'm not talking about that
and it's not a utopian vision we're
talking about how to have happiness in
the home if the husband is not looking
all over the place and his only source
of sexual satisfaction is his wife you
know when he comes home he looks at her
and Islam also encourages the spouses to
look good for each other in the home you
know I'm the love not best the great
companion may Allah be pleased to them
before he would walk into the house he
would start combing his hair perfume
himself fix his clothes up you know and
he said look I like to look good for my
wife just as I like her to look good for
me you know where there's where this has
encouraged the spouses to dress for one
another so you have the husband who
walks into the house with I and takes
off his clothes right away with
ironically with what's called a wife
beater if you've got the wife in her and
winnie-the-pooh pajamas with cream all
over her face whenever the husband comes
home and he's just seeing all those
billboards that you're talking about now
he's looking at his wife in that state
and she's saying where have you been and
what's wrong with you then you know
you're obviously creating something very
unhealthy so the wife will look
elsewhere for satisfaction the husband
will look elsewhere for satisfaction
whether it's in the form of a virtual
satisfaction in the form of pornography
which unfortunately is you know is
killing killing God not to start youth
today married couples today test
life-altering effects yeah right so I
mean that you just will never be able to
have happiness in your marriage so
that's why Islam encourages you focus
your gaze on your spouse whenever you
you get married you should look for
someone one of the things that you
should look for someone that you're
attracted to there's no doubt about it
but once you're once you're there you're
there that's it when I take a break and
we drive back for more here I show one
God worship Him alone do what he wants
you to do put your desire is this thing
inside you that just wants this and
wants that and you just can't get enough
you know what you'll never get enough
until the dirts in your mouth don't let
it come to that be sincere and honest
ask the one who created you to guide
race the first step put off chasing all
the women and the good times and the
parties and this and that there is no
one worthy of voice it except Allah
don't wait you never know if death would
come today for you back here on the Deen
show with Sheikh Omar Suleiman thank you
for being with us once again we all
could we're almost out of time these
sessions are very short so we encourage
people to continue tuning in to the Deen
show and to follow up with maybe taking
some of your classes at the mish Kat
calm mr. Kai universe miss Kat
University well mug it up if it's ever
and I'll attach them Morgan yeah so
Anna's knowledge I mean it's not about
just being one who's Muslim by name
it's about seeking knowledge being upon
knowledge of people of action and you
need to have not only the good intention
but knowledge precedes actions is that
correct right so now that we have the
knowledge we know that Islam is the way
of life that was lived throughout time
by all the messengers of God submission
to the One God and
we have it preserved to this day Tamra
free tamper-proof is based on evidence
and if anyone takes a scientific
analytical approach they'll come to the
same conclusion that you did you read
the Bible and you went through many
different religions doing a comparative
study and you concluded I've concluded
1.5 billion people concluded this is the
way of life from the crater it's not
man-made because we shouldn't have to
follow organized religion organized by
men but from the crater now tell us we
know this and now we want to stay away
from pornography gambling alcohol and
all the evil things that produce evil
results and one of the best ways for a
man is to get married here comes the
question brothers now okay the sister
you know she's a let's say we're all
struggling we all have deficiencies
right now the brothers looking for a 10
and beauty he's looking for a 10 and
Dean but you know it's been 10 years
it's been 10 years he's looking now now
either the brothers fast and everyday
because we know what's bombarding us out
there all right right and it's really
difficult so or the brother you know he
might be indulging in pornography and so
we're just keeping it real on daddy show
right right cuz we have real issues so
this is not something that is a joke
it's something serious tell us now is
this something detrimental to him
finding the woman because now for the
lesser evil he might have put this in
his mind he's enjoying the pornography
and now he takes a look at his sister
he's like nah that's not for me and he
keeps on he's been going through this
for 10 years this is a problem with him
and is this hindering his path the
pornography the self pleasure and all
this well the thing is is that you know
in the issue of marriage you know the
first thing that if you go to a car
dealership what's the first thing the
dealer is gonna try to get you to do
take it for a test drive a test drive
yeah you know enjoy the leather seating
enjoy the rims enjoy just enjoy that so
that you ignore the price tag and you
ignore the the things that really make
it counts and in essence and in no way
shape or form am i comparing a sister or
a brother to a used car to a car in
essence what the car dealer wants to
make you do is make an emotional
decision rather than a rational decision
and Islam wants you to make a rational
decision and in order to make that
rational
you need to avoid things that would
distract you that would hurt your
rationality so obviously when you look
at these glorified individuals online
people that aren't real looking you know
and and you know you indulge in that
then nothing is going to satisfy the eye
anymore and again everything a lot
legislates is for your own good also
it's for your own good in this world so
a loss trying to make it easy for you so
what I would say to those people because
look I mean let's face it
pornography and those types of it's it's
so rampant and people are struggling
with it that would even be good in other
areas they're good Muslims but they're
struggling with that just think about
the consequences with God think about
having to meet a lot and having to have
that pornography played in front of you
and having to explain to Allah that I
was watching this in front of you
because a lot was watching you the whole
time you know would get awkward if
someone was watching you while you're
watching porn out yeah a lot was
watching you so this is killing your
relationship with God because in essence
back to the psychology of a teeter
you're purposely trying to ignore God at
those moments no one is sitting there
reading Quran while they're watching
pornography or remembering God they're
trying to forget that God's watching
them at that at that moment so remember
God is watching you and as a scholar
said anta to rock to rock you belong you
know kabuki you are an observance of a
law and a laws and observance of you you
know so that's that's what I would say
to those brothers in that way inshallah
whenever the time comes you save
yourself for the right sister sister
save yourself for the right brother
then inshallah you would find that you
would find that satisfaction in looking
at them and you would find that
satisfaction and being with them and the
superficial aspects of beauty would
definitely go away but the inner beauty
would be your focus and that would allow
the person to remain beautiful in your
eyes for the rest of your life and so
definitely before we go - before we cut
out the person now we should be striving
Deen is the most important Deen Islam
that the person is praying for I'm the
woman and she's into Islam she's not
have fifty fifty Ramadan Muslims you
know what I mean so they're in the Deen
now let's say she's not or he's not a
ten they might be a seven lower your
standards we'll obviously there needs to
be some attraction correct right but now
if we're like putting this person we
want a JLo we want you know
what we perceive as something that's the
most beautiful paintbrush women you know
to mean or paintbrush men right the Brad
Pitt's and whatever well but if you see
some of these people in person you know
they're miserable and most of them are
on drugs
and if you see them without committing
suicide and if you really see them at
maybe if you went to one of these after
parties we're not supposed to be going
and you see em you're like man this
person is actually ugly right they don't
have all right there of course you know
you see millennium out there for them
like this is not what I thought this was
supposed to be a person who submitted to
god they got newer coming out of their
face like coming so a person has
disobeying God we live in a legal
lifestyle they don't have nor but
they're painted up paintbrush people
right so now if you look at a person you
really want to fulfill half your Deen
and we're trying to motivate the
brothers and sisters so now you put your
criteria Deen is first and you lower
your expectation lose a little bit man
if you do this for a law you do it right
you know what I mean
a law is the button that puts love is in
the heart not saying that you go with
someone that's totally you can't even
just you know look at them but man
there's something a little bit there do
you want to just go forward and said
another 20 years and you're missing out
having children you're missing out on
all the all of this good well the real
talk is that you know what you should
have married someone that you're
completely unattractive yeah okay so
it's important but the basis of your
pursuits should be religion and
character religion and character the
Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him said
you look for those two things in essence
character the word hope and Islam and
this is a linguistic you know this is
some lingo but the word hadoken Islam
means inner beauty and Hulk means outer
beauty so we make the door along with my
son to help the a symbolically Oh Allah
as you have beautified my outside
beautify my inside so we look for we
look for the inner beauty of a person
the way that they treat their parents
the way they treat people the way they
carry themselves those are
manifestations of inner beauty and
character and then we consider the other
aspects we consider beauty we consider
status we consider those things but
again if the first who are there the
Dean and the whole of the religion and
the character then the other things you
know need to be satisfactory you can't
find a person who's perfect in all
categories
that's for Jinnah that's for gentlemen
that's for Jinnah thank you very much
we're out of time I wish we can
some more I'm really benefiting I'm sure
the viewers are also may god almighty
the greater rewards heaven we thank you
for being with us again go and take his
class I'm gonna you have a class coming
up on comparative religion actually I'm
starting right now so semester right now
compared to religion what's this guy
University what's it called its called
religions and doctrines religions and
doctrines when does it start it's
starting in a few weeks in a few weeks
how can people sign up you could go to
Michigan University calm and also I'll
be teaching a course with ILF Houston or
it'll be online about refuting
misconceptions about Islam and of course
with a negative Institute I'm focusing
on spirituality now the online one you
got more room for people can I can I
join this class absolutely every Tuesday
night I want to come I want to learn I
want to benefit I love this topic when
we talk about just Islam in general but
especially when we talk about
comparative religions I'll see you there
insha'Allah God willing I'll see you
there to make sure you're you're here
with our brother our Sheikh so we can
benefit get the knowledge be closer to
Allah we'll see you next time Michelle
on today's show okay so thank you and
thank you for tuning in to another
episode of the Deen show I got to
benefit inshallah God willing you did
also continue to tune in here every week
and the main message is look this life
is short we're gonna die there's a day
of judgment and then there's the reward
a paradise and we want to get to
paradise because this life is transitory
it's gonna pass everything's in the past
tense I was there been there done that
and at the end you're a loser because
you lose this life than you lose the
next don't lose the next life for this
light be the best that you can in this
life but prepare for the next prepare to
meet your Creator and the only way that
you can be successful is by doing all
the good that he's told us to do
continue to tune and get the new DVD
dunya to Deen and if you like what we
had to say and you want to embrace the
way of life of all the messages of God
don't hesitate be courageous enough it's
that simple call to worship the creator
not his creation give us a call 1 800
662
Islam Islam and you will end up being
truly living your purpose being
successful in this life in the next
we'll see you next time
inshallah God willing peace
young to you